the Twilight Saga will always be
remembered for popularizing the trend of
Supernatural romances in the late 2000s
and early 2010s in the first two
installments of the series Twilight and
New Moon relle leev portrayed the
thirstiest of them all the vengeful
vampire Victoria her fiery red hair and
ruthless desire for Bella's blood made
her the perfect villain and a fan
favorite so when news broke that
Victoria was being recast it came as a
surprise to everyone including leev leev
told Access Hollywood I was stunned by
summit's decision to recast the role of
Victoria for eclipse I turned down
several other film opportunities and in
accordance with my contractual rights
accepted only roles that would involve
very short shooting schedules one of
those roles was for a project called
Barney's version which overlapped 10
days with eclipse's 3-month shooting
schedule Summit responded by claiming
leev withheld disclosing the scheduling
conflict for more than a month feeling
as though Lev's actions put the
production at risk Bryce Dallas Howard
was cast to take her place really leev
didn't lose out on too much since her
character's death at the end of the
movie Would Have Made It her last
appearance anyway